[Aplausos]
[Música]
qué tal amigas y espero que la audiencia
masculina en este momento
y traiga esa mentalidad femenina traigan
a sus antepasadas mujeres indígenas
cuando era niña mi hermana se ponía un
cinto colorido y decía con este cinto
parezco india
yo era muy pequeña le contestaba no
apareces eres indígena
para hablar del futuro necesitamos
reconocer nuestro pasado
para hablar del futuro necesitamos estar
100% en el momento presente es por eso
que nuestras antepasadas ancestrales nos
acompañan y si yo supe de mi origen
desde edad muy temprana no porque en
méxico estemos muy orgullosos de eso no
es porque mi madre él odia aguirre soto
se encargó de escudriñar el árbol
genealógico
y ella dijo que nuestras antepasadas
bisabuelas era rara maurice l of a soto
y cirilo ya están aquí conmigo siempre
al estado siempre han estado en estas
manos en estos ojos en estos labios en
esta en este vientre en este corazón en
estas piernas en estos pies rarámuris
siempre han estado lo reconozco
especialmente en el habla porque cuando
yo aprendí a hablar inglés otra lengua
de construir la casa del amor ahí con su
lenguaje con la lengua dominando y me
imaginaba que ellas mis bisabuelos
cuando hablaba en español pasaban largas
horas de silencio porque así me sucedía
a mí está bisnieta que está aquí jugó
jugó con el lenguaje y experimentó en
mujeres cósmicas que es mujeres cósmicas
me pregunta elena poniatowska en un
correo reciente mujeres cósmicas
es un libro orgánico es un libro hecho
en rizoma ese planta ese ser que le
surgen con creaciones o creaciones en
forma vertical en ella o eso estando en
el estado horizontal
eso es mujeres cósmicas mujeres cósmicas
al experimentar con el lenguaje y la
literatura me libero me libero
yo escribía la historia de 11
identidades y afuera estaba la guerra
en una ocasión en el 2009 el 31 de
octubre del 2009 vino carlos fuentes a
esta frontera la última vez que visitó
este lugar
en ciudad juárez se vivía la guerra
contra el narcotráfico
yo era articulista en el periódico local
maestra de preparatoria y escribía
sobre la masacre
de los jóvenes de salvárcar de ciudad
juárez fui buscando una respuesta en el
autor cuál fue mi sorpresa no escuchar
absolutamente nada con respecto a lo que
vivíamos la ciudad yo para entonces en
el 2009 todavía buscaba respuestas del
padre del hombre del autor
si tenía la definición de escritor de
autoría como ellos
son hombres son blancos poderosos
y entonces supe que el juego literario
no solamente se queda en los libros
salta a los niveles de jerarquía y salta
a las relaciones cuando iba yo poder
llegar allá entonces me enteré me enteré
y supe que yo debería escribir y
escribir una novela autobiográfica
polvos de manzana
todavía no le podía decir las cosas por
su nombre no conocía el feminismo era
insegura mujer un producto una
consecuencia del machismo cultural que
nos embarga
en méxico hemos desaparecido a nuestras
antepasadas en mexico la violencia ha
alcanzado niveles insospechados en
mexico desaparecen 70 personas al día y
hay 3000 feminicidios anuales
entonces con ese méxico yo dije voy a
experimentar y voy a hacer todo lo
contrario la novela autobiográfica se
quedó guardada porque pensaba que a
nadie le importaba conocer mi historia
después le siguió mujeres cósmicas sí y
vino a través de un sueño un sueño de
una serpiente que escupe aceite verde
por el hocico una serpiente que llegó y
entró a mi psique a mi departamento y
empecé a escribir yo pensé que aquello
que le salía era veneno no era néctar
porque después viajé a la sierra de
oaxaca y ahí se coló la voz o maría
sabina maría sabina la curandera maría
sabina
la que maneja las plantas maría sabina
indígena mazateca se coló su voz en mi
psique y continué la escritura de 11
mujeres herederas de una extraña fortuna
que les transfiere poderes de toda
índole entonces esa serpiente machista
no se podía apropiar de las identidades
de los demás no podía hacer lo que la
literatura con l mayúscula venía
haciendo hasta ese momento
lo que dice cristina rivera garza que
hace esa literatura con l mayúscula
apropiarse de las experiencias y las
historias de otros y de otras en
beneficio de ella misma y entonces
engorda y es violenta y es machista y es
patriarcal
no no lo iba a permitir porque llegaron
mis antepasados rarámuris y dijeron
vamos a sanar y vamos a liberar y así
fue ya la primera que libere fue a mí
misma usé después de 365 días de
escribir realidades paralelas y
registrar los sueños puse el libro en
internet en el 2011 claro el rechazo era
de esperarse si me habían rechazado
durante siglos porque no lo habrían
hacer de hacer ahora en el 2011 en aquel
tiempo siendo mujer experimentando en
esta frontera con tanta violencia lo
hicieron no importa tuve que intervenir
mi novela en cuatro ocasiones el libro
lo interviene en cuatro ocasiones le
cambia la portada en cuatro ocasiones
pero que queden
a esa novela como era rizoma le esperaba
otro destino
su intención original fue floreciendo y
llegaron cuatro creaciones de varias por
venir
la primera arpías cómicas y la sátira de
la psique de la novelista gráfica malena
villar después vio danza y mujeres
cósmicas de la sicóloga juarense tenis
villarreal después llegó el tratado
político de mujeres cósmicas de marcela
magdaleno
luego la creación más reciente mujeres
cósmicas ser pentón es demandante una
propuesta para el fin de la guerra entre
las lenguas el inglés y el español lo
más importante es el origen de la teoría
del feminismo cósmico ahora yo estoy a
punto de terminar un doctorado en
educación enseñanza aprendizaje y
cultura y estoy generando esa teoría del
feminismo o al feminismo todos los
feminismos el liberal el radical el
marxista los feminismos que luchan por
la equidad y no han costado una sola
gota de sangre
esos feminismos dialógicos los
feminismos de las feministas
comunitarias que quieren la paz y la
sanación de nuestros cuerpos los cuerpos
de las mujeres hemos sido históricamente
explotados y los espacios favoritos de
la explotación las feministas
comunitarias julieta paredes dice
y la explotación ya estaba aquí cuando
llegaron los españoles los hombres
nativos ya las usaban ya las explotaban
el feminismo comunitario quiere la
sanación y dice vamos a sanar nuestros
cuerpos y vamos a ponerlo como el camino
cósmico político eso es feminismo
cósmico pero yo no fui la primera porque
encontré un artículo académico sobre el
feminismo cósmico de concha michelle
concha michel protofeminista cantante de
corridos que se asegura que en sus
letras siempre regresemos a nuestras
raíces ancestrales ella era comunista
ella es la primera feminista cósmica de
nuestro país y ya estaba aquí las
mujeres nos enseñamos a las mujeres las
mujeres platicamos entre nosotras y
escuchando a nuestras antepasadas
nosotros vamos a llegar a varias
conclusiones importantes
es momento de la escritura
es momento de que pongamos las manos en
las palabras y no tengamos miedo a
contar nuestras historias y los vamos a
hacer en formato testimonial esto estaba
sucediendo cuando allá afuera alguien
una mente violenta y machista generaba
una guerra
esto sucedía yo lo digo con estas
palabras y lo vamos a hacer desde la
conciencia la conciencia cual la de la
nueva mestiza
la nueva mestiza es una teoría generada
por gloria ansaldo a donde dice que a
las mexicanas nos guían tres ejes la
malinche la llorona y la virgen de
guadalupe
la malinche desde la mirada patriarcal
fue la traidora ella dominaba varios
idiomas sus lenguas serpientes
y luego la universal hizo a lo misógino
octavio paz
en hijos de la malinche
fin del mito por favor
luego el siguiente eje la llorona la
mujer que lo pierde y llora y sufre y le
duele y llora y vuelve a llorar y le
vuelve a doler y el patriarca y el
capitalista genera una industria
alrededor de ese dolor
después el otro eje el de la virgen la
virgen de guadalupe así como ella es tu
debe ser para merecer esos tres ejes se
mezclan y forman la conciencia de la
nueva mestiza pero la nueva mestiza no
es un mito es real es habitante de la
frontera
se crea a través de sus luchas a través
de su historia
la nueva mestiza y entonces escribe y
entonces dialoga y entonces habla y
entonces se escucha a través de su
cuerpo necesitamos nuestros cuerpos
sanos para poder manifestar la realidad
que nosotros queremos y entonces a
mujeres cósmicas experimenté e hice todo
lo contrario al que se había hecho una
literatura hasta ese momento no podía
ser un éxito desde los términos
capitalistas mujeres cósmicas en mujeres
cósmicas delibere pero redefinir las
palabras éxito pedagogía porque en mis
clases de creación literaria yo había
sido llamada loca síndrome del útero me
dolió profundamente a susana chávez
castillo poeta y activista de ciudad
juárez le dijeron que no tenía futuro
como poeta en los talleres de creación
literaria entonces con esa problemática
reconfigure el título de la cátedra
y el vi doctorado entonces le pongo
escritura crítica orgánica esa voz que
las mujeres estamos desarrollando
armónicamente fin de las guerras
no podemos continuar desaparecidas en el
estado de texas los mexicanos no
aparecemos en los libros de texto las
mexicanas tampoco como si no formáramos
parte de la historia en el estado de
chihuahua las mujeres en la literatura
la representación es muy muy baja
estamos casi desaparecidas
a susana chávez la asesina del 5 de
enero del 2011
susana chávez amiga poeta y activista
dicen chimamanda y magos y nigeriana
feminista y escritora la literatura debe
servir para rebasar los niveles de la
imaginación y entonces reestructurar
nuestras relaciones y abolir el machismo
y el racismo
susana chávez castillo vive susana
chávez castillo escribe dice arminé
arjona una poeta local
y sí
estoy de acuerdo susana chávez vive
porque los asesinos no conformes con
masacrar la le cortaron una mano
susana vive y susana escribe porque
tiene mis manos y tiene las manos de las
escritoras latinoamericanas
frases
[Aplausos]
[Música]